[Música]
continúa la atención en Perú donde se
registraron fuertes enfrentamientos
entre grupos de manifestantes y la
policía en Lima las autoridades
informaron de daños severos en la
infraestructura del centro histórico
además 120 puntos de Vidas nacionales
registraron bloqueos
miles de estadounidenses protestaron en
contra del aborto a unos días del
aniversario número 50 de la sentencia
que protegía la interrupción voluntaria
del embarazo a nivel Federal pero fue
derogada en junio los manifestantes
aseguraron que seguirán luchando Hasta
que el aborto sea algo impensable
a prisión preventiva fue enviado al
futbolista brasileño Dani Alves jugador
del Fútbol Club Barcelona el deportista
es señalado por presunta violación su
testimonio contradictorio sembró dudas
entre las autoridades de ahí la decisión
de dejarlo bajo custodia
Bienvenidos a esta informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos comenzamos en
Perú donde crece la atención Pues
continúan los enfrentamientos entre la
policía y grupos de manifestantes en la
llamada toma de Lima las autoridades
estiman que los daños materiales
causados hasta el momento ascienden a
210 mil dólares y denunciaron que hubo
fuertes y severas afectaciones en la
infraestructura del centro histórico no
obstante no solo la capital se vio
afectada este viernes 120 puntos de vías
nacionales fueron bloqueados al tiempo
que el aeropuerto de Arequipa mantuvo
sus operaciones suspendidas
posibles ataques Andrés triviño nos
amplía la información
continúan las protestas en Perú las vías
a lo largo del país permanecen
bloqueadas mientras que en la capital
Lima las protestas terminaron nuevamente
en enfrentamientos entre manifestantes y
la fuerza pública yo sus propias leyes a
su beneficio cumpli
Endo en ello están regidos ellos lejos
de escuchar nuestra voz los gobernantes
han mandado a aniquilar a nuestros
hermanos a masacrar a nuestros pueblos
entonces hemos tenido que mandar a
nuestros hermanos a nuestros esposos a
nuestros hijos a la capital para que
sean escuchados
esos enfrentamientos marcan la peor
violencia que Perú ha visto en más de 20
años y que afecta a 18 de los 24
departamentos del país las autoridades
de la capital estiman que sufrieron
pérdidas materiales por al menos 210 mil
dólares durante la denominada toma de
Lima el 19 de enero que dejó imágenes
como estas las manifestaciones llevan
casi dos meses y por ahora el gobierno
de Dina boluarte se aferra al poder
asegurando que realizará investigaciones
para determinar las más de 50 muertes
que han dejado las protestas Mientras
tanto en cusco al menos 300 turistas se
encuentran varados por las protestas
luego de que manifestantes bloquearan el
tren que conduce a Machu Picchu eso
sería todo ahorita estamos pues con la
incertidumbre de saber si va a venir va
a venir algún tren a recogernos como
verán todos los turistas aquí estamos
haciendo una cola para Pues están
recolectando firma y está bien
empadronando
entre tanto los manifestantes han
asegurado que mantendrán las protestas
hasta que vean cambios aumentando la
inestabilidad en un país que ha tenido
seis presidentes en los últimos seis
años justamente hablando de Perú
finalizó en la ciudad Suiza de davos el
foro económico mundial y Daniela
hablandon enviado especial de France 24
pudo hablar con el presidente del Banco
Central de Perú le pregunto Cuáles son
las proyecciones de crecimiento teniendo
en cuenta el impacto de estas protestas
un poco por debajo de 3%. 2.8 2,9 Qué es
una de las más altas en la región de
todas maneras y esperamos llegar a
inflación de 3% también a fin de año no
la inflación subyacente
sino inflación total Estados Unidos
declaró al grupo paramilitar ruso Wagner
como una organización criminal
transnacional se estima que la
agrupación cuenta con unos 50.000
efectivos que actualmente están
desplegados en Ucrania y según datos de
Estados Unidos unos 40.000 habrían sido
reclutados de prisiones rusas el grupo
fue el que tomó el control de Soledad
esta disputada zona y ahora se teme que
ataque bahamut y la de esta Victoria
Rusia previamente conversamos con lios
sassday analista de relaciones
internacionales y estudios estratégicos
de fuerzas terrestres navales aéreas y
espaciales rusas que nos explicó Qué
significa Y qué implica esta
denominación de Estados Unidos
bueno es una forma para incrementar el
volumen vamos a decir de las sanciones y
Pues digamos que ya que se enfoque en la
atención internacional más de lo que
está de lo que se ve en las noticias y
se habla del grupo Wagner Pues que se
aumente digamos que el enfoque pero de
manera punitiva a través de sanciones
porque claro las sanciones
norteamericanas pues se hacen eco entre
los aliados y esto puede llevar a
sanciones y no se han hecho ya por otros
miembros no de de la alianza atlántica
de la otan y eventualmente pues puede
llevar a ser un argumento para poner en
el banquillo los acusados si algún día
se logra no capturando algunos de los
responsables de usados de crímenes de
guerra del grupo Wagner pues vincularlo
actividades criminales transnacionales
como parte de los cargos en su contra la
ciudad de Washington capital Estados
Unidos Fue escenario de una
multitudinaria marcha de ciudadanos en
contra de la interrupción del embarazo
Solo dos días antes del aniversario
número 50 de la sentencia que protegía
el derecho al aborto a nivel Federal
el aborto Nunca ha dejado de ser eje
central de la escena política
estadounidense miles de manifestantes
protagonizaron la anual marcha por la
vida en las calles de Washington la
primera sin el aborto legal en Estados
Unidos tras la decisión de la corte de
derogar la decisión de 1973 en dos días
se habrían cumplido 50 años del
histórico fallo de Row versus weight con
el que la Corte Suprema protegió
federalmente el derecho de una mujer a
interrumpir su embarazo
nos está mostrando y dando Esperanza que
los jóvenes de Estados Unidos apoyan la
vida defienden la vida están aquí para
marchar por la vida porque cuando estás
en una batalla es importante mantener el
enfoque de Cuál es la misión pero en
cada paso del camino también es
fundamental que celebremos las victorias
y obtuvimos una gran Victoria hace solo
unos meses cuando Rose fue anulado
los manifestantes buscan ahora
restricciones al aborto a nivel Federal
en contrapartida el presidente Joe biden
afirmó que continuará sus esfuerzos por
restaurar el derecho al aborto en todo
el país
Mi administración se mantiene firme en
su compromiso para defender los derechos
reproductivos y continuar el progreso de
nuestra nación hacia la igualdad para
todos este caso reafirmó principios
básicos de igualdad reforzó el derecho
fundamental a la privacidad y sostuvo
que las mujeres de este país podían
controlar su propio destino tomando
decisiones profundamente personales
libres de injerencia política
sin las protecciones que otorgaba Rover
versus Wayne el aborto se convirtió en
territorio de disputas judicial en todos
los estados desde junio una docena de
ellos han implementado prohibiciones
casi totales mientras que tribunales
estatales bloquearon esfuerzos similares
en otros tres estados unidos oscila
entre las perturbaciones generadas a los
derechos reproductivos y el deseo de
mayores prohibiciones reflejo de una
sociedad altamente polarizada en Ciudad
de México cientos de ciudadanos
protestaron en contra de la
militarización del metro los
manifestantes aseguraron que no es la
solución adecuada y condenaron esta
medida ordenada por la alcaldesa Claudia
sheinbaum que permite el despliegue de
la guardia nacional en las estaciones en
medio de las movilizaciones grupos de
ciudadanos cometieron actos vandálicos
al destrozar algunas tiendas
es la solución el futbolista brasileño
Dani Alves ex jugador del Fútbol Club
Barcelona fue enviado a prisión
preventiva por presunta violación según
Fuentes judiciales las contradicciones
en las versiones de los hechos dadas por
el jugador fueron algunos de los motivos
para ser detenido
prisión preventiva sin fianza para Dani
Alves por presunta violación es El
veredicto de una jueza de Barcelona tras
considerar que existe riesgo de fuga
luego de conocerse la noticia su actual
club El Pumas mexicano ha rescindido su
contrato con esta decisión el club
reitera su compromiso de no tolerar
actos de ningún integrante de nuestra
institución
sea quien sea que atenten contra el
espíritu universitario y sus valores la
decisión judicial llega por petición del
fiscal y de la defensa luego de escuchar
los testimonios de la víctima y del
futbolista el de ella concuerda con los
registros de las cámaras de una
discoteca de Barcelona el pasado 30 de
diciembre Dani Alves parece
contradecirse sea quien sea el presunto
agresor la ley solo Sí o sí protege a
todas las mujeres las mujeres que sufren
cualquier tipo de violencia sexual
cuentan con la protección del Estado
solo sí es sí un lema feminista que se
convirtió en ley en agosto de 2022 de
España un texto por el que la ministra
de igualdad Irene Montero ha recibido
duros ataques de la oposición de
derechas la ley Busca aumentar la
atención y protección a las víctimas con
ella Alves enfrentará a una posible pena
de entre 4 y 12 años de cárcel
informativo volvemos en breve
[Música]